- [Baz] Standing by.
- [Crew] Marker.
(marker claps)
- And action.
- Oscar memories.
(Rian vocalizing)
- Can it just be any memory?
- Yeah.
(inspirational music)
- Well, my biggest memory is
when Julia Roberts won for Erin Brockovich
and I just remember the way
she sauntered up on the stage.
(audience cheering)
(Julia laughing)
- I remember Olivia Coleman's speech
which I thought was a class speech.
(audience cheering)
- Thank you.
- Billy Crystal.
And Billy Crystal.
- The thing that was most powerful for me
was being able to meet people whose words
and works inspired me.
(Santiago speaking Spanish)
(Ricardo laughing)
(Santiago continues speaking Spanish)
- You had Spielberg, you had
Jack Nicholson down the front.
- Next to him, there was Warren Beatty.
- It scared the crap outta me.
- I thought I'd be able to be a cool cat
who stays chill, but I
emphatically was not.
- Instead of saying cheers with my drink,
I said cheers with the Oscar.
And accidentally I got a
big scratch on my Oscar.
(Anders laughs)
And I'm not sure to this day
if Brad Pitt also has a
scratch on his Oscar. (laughs)
- Actually met Snoop Dogg,
got a selfie with him.
It's still the picture on my
Facebook page to this day.
- I remember my father-
- [Baz] Oh God.
- Who was my date,
running away from me at the speed of light
because he'd seen Julie Andrews
and was determined to have a
long conversation with her.
- The shoe of my wife fell very low
into the dungeons of the theater,
so you know why she had just one shoe.
(audience cheering)
- I think about Oscars,
mostly it's just about
a celebration of art.
- I absolutely loved the moment when Rayka
won for "Period. End of sentence" in 2019.
- Period. End of sentence.
(crowd cheering)
- I always looked at Leo's career
and getting to see him go
up there for "The Revenant",
I felt very happy for him.
- That was the Oscars that Darlene Love,
one of the greatest voices
in American music history
brought the house down.
♪ And I know ♪
- I remember when "Parasite" won.
- Parasite.
(audience cheering)
- The entire room just exploded
and I have no idea what it
felt like watching it on TV,
but in the room, it felt
like a rock concert.
- The "Parasite" sweep
was one of the greatest
things that's ever happened.
- We had one of those nights
where we had 11 wins
out of 11 nominations.
- Lord of the Rings.
- Lord of the Rings,
the Return Of the King.
- And we partied in Peter
Jackson's room all night long.
- Myself and my whole family,
we were in front of the
TV with all excitement
when my friend Mr. AR Rahman-
- AR Rahman.
(crowd cheers)
- Surprisingly he got two
Oscars on the same day.
- We had a projector
and a projection screen
and cooked up a storm.
And we're watching the awards.
And Joel and Ethan win for
best original screenplay.
- Ethan and Joel Cohen, for "Fargo".
(crowd cheers)
- And in the middle of
the speech, Joel says-
- I'd like to thank everyone
over at Mary Zophres' house.
I guess this woke you guys up.
- And the room, my house went bonkers.
It was one of the most special experiences
and evenings of my life.